you watch anime definitely I got this
game called Blind rankings I'mma say
anime you can only rank it once Dragon
Ball Z two Dragon Ball Z number two that
was a quick two two okay one piece I
didn't really get into one piece and if
you didn't start like and I grew up with
it there's so many episodes I'm gonna
put a five what about bleach fourth
didn't watch it Demon Slayer I'm gonna
put them on Slayer three Naruto
definitely one Dragon Ball Z and now
it's all my top two Dragon Ball Z was
the one that basically every single time
after school I would literally just run
back to making them time because they
always just play one episode I wanted to
make it on time for that